an Allstate commercial from March 2023
features Winters once again as Mayhem
taking the form of your highly
competitive older brother whose overly
aggressive basketball playing turns a
friendly pickup game into a potentially
costly repair job the other brother the
one whose garage gets wrecked is mostly
kept in the background as Mayhem Hogs
both the ball and the scene but it
didn't take long for fans to recognize
him as Winter's real life brother and
former Oz and homicide co-star Scott
William Winter the two Winters Brothers
began their onscreen careers at around
the same time in the mid1 1990s and
Scott has also played his share of cops
and criminals his most recognizable role
may just be one of his earliest Scott
plays the Harvard blo hard that gets
shown up by Matt Damon in the 1997 drama
Goodwill Hunting how do you like them
app the scene and its instantly
memorable punchline was parody four
years later in Kevin Smith's J and
Silent Bob Strike Back